there is an absolutely horrifying viral
video
out of los angeles of lapd shooting a
woman
at point-blank range with what is
believed to be either a rubber
rubber bullet or a beanbag round there's
actually conflicting repo
reports about this we are going to look
at the video the video is it's sort of
graphic it's certainly
it's certainly disturbing it's it's sort
of graphic just as a warning
um and we are going to look at that
momentarily but first some reports about
this
video shows lapd officers shoot
protester at close range with non-lethal
round
outside koreatown spa
video shows an lapd lapd officer
shooting a non-lethal round at a
protester
at close range as the department
responded to a clash between two groups
who held dueling demonstrations outside
a koreatown spa
over trans rights on saturday that was
the impetus
for this protest when officers arrived
in riot gear protesters started throwing
bottles and projectiles according to
authorities
some of them were pelted at officers
which prompted them to issue an order to
disperse
when some groups failed to leave less
than lethal force was deployed
the viral video shows one officer firing
the rubber bullet hitting a protester in
the stomach
she is seen falling to the ground the
woman's condition
was not immediately available there's
then another report
lgbtq plus activist shot with rubber
bullet
in la protest la lgbtq
activists gathered to counter a protest
against
trans access to the spas facilities in
la's koreatown neighborhood
the video shows lapd pointing guns at
demonstrators shooting rubberized
bullets using batons and pushing
journalists
one counter protester was shot with a
rubber bullet after shouting don't shoot
lapd captain alfonso lopez said in a
video interview shared on social
that police responded to projectiles
being thrown he stated the police
arrested 38 people so let's look at the
video
um and of course what's at issue here is
whether this particular protester i
don't deny for a second that there were
bottles being thrown at police uh
i saw videos of that i don't deny for a
second that an
uh an order to disperse was given the
question is why was this particular
person
shot at point blank range which by the
way is not the way
rubberized bullets are supposed to be
used let's take a look for those who are
watching here with us
so the woman holding a phone and you see
people rushing over to her as we
continue
to uh to to look at this and uh
at almost point-blank range just an
unbelievable
video and again it's one of these things
where if there's an explanation for why
that's reasonable
uh i'm having a hard time even imagining
it because we
see what the woman is holding rubber
bullets are
very dangerous at close range most
police department policies have really
specific rules like a minimum distance
when these are going to be used
or when it comes to bean bag rounds i
believe it's you bounce them off the
ground or you'd only target legs or
these are for dangerous non-compliant
individuals
not someone who has their hands up
saying don't shoot
holding a phone um and so
of course you immediately see
the um right-wingers come out and say
well she shouldn't have been there there
was an
order to disperse where are they
on that exact explanation for ashley
babbitt who
was trespassing remember this was not at
the capitol this was out on the street
um and the incredible hypocrisy that we
are seeing
particularly because of this ashley
babbitt trump riot january 6th story
makes the
crocodile tears hear about well
she shouldn't have been there she was
breaking
no she wasn't actually no she wasn't
there was an order to disperse
and the interpretation of how quickly
that's supposed to happen is much like
resisting arrest something that police
will often use
to start using more force than is
necessary or than is indicated
uh rubber bullets not even being used in
compliance with policy rubber of course
makes it sound
it doesn't it's rubber it's sort of like
if someone throws a beach ball
at you um no rubber bullets
can be lethal they can be used
improperly and can be lethal
and i'm not even listen by the way
i'm not in favor of shooting the
anti-trans protesters
or the pro-trans protesters i don't want
any of them shot if people
are just protesting there's another
layer here of course
which is that there was an anti-trans
protest
going on outside the spa which triggered
counter-protesters who are pro-trans
rights
and it's the pro-trans rights counter
protester
who ends up getting herself shot somehow
the police still ended up shooting her
uh that's just sort of like a detail of
i'd call it irony but that makes it
sound less tragic than it actually is
but just horrifying horrifying video and
we're still getting more information
about this um we'll continue to follow
it and see what we ultimately find out
again the the protester who was shot's
condition
i was not able to find anything
definitive at least this morning when i
was researching the story
about what is going on with her at this
time but horrible horrible video
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the delicious breakfast cereal that
tastes
just like those cereals i loved as a kid
but
with zero grams of sugar only four net
carbs
and packed with 13 grams of protein
magic spoon has been advertising with us
for a really long time and it's only
because
our audience loves magic spoon so much
and people
keep buying it that's how you know that
it's good
magic spoon is great if you are doing
low carb
or keto it's perfect if you just want to
eat less sugar like me
it comes in flavors like cocoa fruity
frosted
peanut butter blueberry and cinnamon
you can build your own variety pack and
try them all
the whole david pakman show team loves
magic spoon the blueberry one is one i'm
i'm liking that one recently
it's crunchy it's delicious it's sweet
but not loaded with sugar and carbs
go to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video
and you'll save five dollars when you
use the promo code
pacman at checkout